che ho filippo anche questa volta sei
stato contatto ciclo dell'anno
appuntamenti di oggi sono i legni alle
17 e caterina le 22
ciao
[Musica]
considerando l'operazione il suo corpo
ha risposto alla grande se non fosse per
alcune conseguenze particolarmente
importanti
[Musica]
importante che sei vivo ti dirò o quella
qualcosa secondo me anche migliorata
l'importante che sei vivo
ma mi trovi così tanto diverso filippo
ai 16 un altro
ciao piccolina
dalle nostre possibilità mandami da max
[Musica]
non sei qui per diventare mio amico
mammino discepolo anna gradirebbe del
vino cosa ordine del chiarino allora
inizia così un fiore pur nel suo nome
potrà mai toccate da reid o
mai più innamorarsi di una cliente
mazzarri che significa ma tale che
uccide con i maschietti
oplà quello
tuo fan art è mia io te ma tu
e dice ma calma e poi onu roma
sto meglio bionda si è allora bruna
stava male e difficile
[Musica]